Tori Spelling is pregnant with her fifth  child that's awesome the 43 year old  announced the news to people telling the  mag quote it was a total surprise but we  always wanted a big family  I'm really excited this will be Tori and  husband daddy McDermott's fifth child  together he also has a 17 year old son  from his previous marriage it is the  craziest thing EG last caught up with  the couple in January where they gushed  over their marriage and family we've had  this like great amazing like rebirth of  a relationship and it's just more  exciting each day's in the best places  it's everything for sure you know I was  just thinking about it on the car ride  over here I was just thinking how  grateful I am and how you know with  gratitude I am that we're still together  and my life is wonderful I have these  wonderful babies with you  I have this wonderful life with you and  I was just thinking about that away over  I'm just I'm so grateful and happy